ain't that amazing historic building
behind those nerdfighters is a post
office hang today's video comes to you
in five parts by though I had to put the
puff on vacation because I'm getting
ready for the very fancy venice biennale
also to buy a couple suits nerdfighters
do you like this shirt jacket combo
because if you do I will wear it at a
party but if you don't I won't right
that wasn't part one that was just a
preface part one the unicorn so over the
last month of living in Amsterdam I have
repeatedly had to use Google Translate
to translate documents from Dutch into
English and even though it's not a
perfect tool obviously you usually get a
sense of what people mean and so you're
able to be at the right places at the
right time or whatever so two nights ago
I had dinner with my dutch translator a
lot and some publishing people and in
the document describing that dinner it
was just you know a list of who was
gonna be there and then the last
sentence of the paragraph with this
which google translated we do not know
which of them will eat the unicorn and i
was like this is gonna be some dinner
because basically hey there are only
three categories of dinners there
dinners where there will be no unicorn
served dinners where you know who eat
the unicorn and then there are the
dinners where you don't find out who's
eating the unicorn till you get there
anyway Hank when we got to the dinner I
immediately volunteered to eat the
unicorn I mean first off I know that
unicorn blood is restored if and
secondly I hate unicorns because the
fact that their blood is restorative is
the reason that Voldemort was able to
you know kill so many nice wizards but
it turns out it was on the menu I ended
up having the sea bass which was also
very good part to Gus it was traded by
Suzanne Ben where Hank as I'm sure you
recall in the Yeti was pregnant with
Henry nerdfighteria made me
illustrations of my favorite out of
print picture book so that I could read
Gus's a bug to Henry but Suzanne with
the extra mile turning her illustrations
for Gus is a bug into an actual book
that Henry loves and my gloves I mean
shoes on I just thought that was amazing
Hank part 3 spoilers so you will notice
that when I was talking about the
unicorn blood I did not say which
Wizards Voldemort kills him off instead
of the years that I don't believe in
spoilers but to borrow a phrase from
President Obama my position on spoilers
is evolving specifically it has evolved
from not believing in them to believing
in them this positional evolution has
happened because my new book is quite
spoiled ball and I realized that
don't want it spoiled for readers so
like nine months in advance I'm going to
begin asking you and nerdfighteria
please don't spoil the book we will work
hard to create safe spoilery places and
then there will be the big unblemished
unspoiled world outside yeah by the way
I got started saying that because people
say that here yeah part for punishment
tank we still haven't decided on
punishments we need to do that this week
yeah part 5 tumblr thank you and I both
been fans of the tumblr f.viia
nerdfighters link in the doobly-doo for
many years but it wasn't until earlier
this month that we both got tumblers we
got him on the same day it's very cute
how we do things on the same day it's
almost as if we're brothers you know who
really looked like each other hang
tumblr seems to be the number one
destination to find nerdfighter jokes
and Looking for Alaska quotations and
dftba tattoos and nerd fight a stick
Google investigations and pizza John
slash Looking for Alaska jokes and
entire websites devoted to Hampi Hank
Hank the Yeti is very amused by humpy
Hanks but when she saw the one where you
hugged me she said it's gone too far
anyway nerdfighters if you're on tumblr
you should definitely follow FBI
nerdfighters you can also follow Hank
he's at Edwards spoon hands which in my
opinion is the most underappreciated
Hank song and in my continuing attempts
to profit from the bounty of the ocean
you can find me at fishing boat proceeds
tumblr comm hey don't forget to be
awesome you'll see more from Bruges on
Friday but first I'll see you on
Wednesday